you as an identity are in your conscious
mind you actually are in there that's
where your personal identity is
and we have a tendency to say if i talk
to myself
i'm going to give myself a good talking
to and i'm going to change that
subconscious i say to myself bruce don't
do that again do this don't do that
again and and then i say it's very
frustrating why
you can talk until you're blue in the
face
and nothing will change i say why and
the answer is and this is the most
important part
there is nobody in the subconscious
there's nothing there it's a machine
it's a record playback device so you can
talk to the machine as much as you want
if you don't know how to push the record
button nothing's going to happen
so then i say how do you change the
program he said how did you get the
program
the first seven years your brain was in
theta hypnosis
so i say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind disconnects just as you fall
into sleep your brain is now operating
in theta
so if you put earphones on your head
and you play a tape a program a cd
of what you want
as your
your conscious mind disconnected
your subconscious is downloading so you
just play that
tape as you go to bed and after a number
of playings your subconscious will learn
the new program without even your
conscience being involved that's number
one
after age seven
how do we put a program in repetition
how did you do anything you repeated it
over and over again how long did it take
you to learn the alphabet how many times
did you have to go from a to zed before
you could remember the whole alphabet
when you drove a car you didn't know how
to drive a car until you did what you
practiced you repeated so if you want to
change a program
you put into your mind a repetition
and it's not
it would recognize this what you want to
change doesn't exist so when you put in
the new program it'll sound strange so
let's say you are sick you have a
disease and i say what program do i want
i am healthy
i go it doesn't sound right i know i'm
sick i say i don't care there's a saying
in english
fake it until you make it
what that means is if you want to be
happy just keep in your mind i am happy
i smile even if you have to force a
smile i am happy i'm smiling i say
repeat this and repeat this and guess
what
after a short time it becomes a habit
and when you're in that habit you don't
even have to think i am happy the new
habit will keep you happy all the time
because that's the new program
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
bruce lipton and my take on his top 10
rules to success enjoy
rule number two identify the stressors
so someone's not feeling well they've
got
i don't know they've got the flu or
they've got something on their stomach
or something
what should they practically do they
should presumably go to the doctor and
get a diagnosis would you go along with
that i'm just just trying to see where
this goes in day-to-day life well i
wouldn't say don't go to a doctor but i
say before you go to a doctor just look
around and think about this what's going
on in your life where the stress is
coming from because it's almost uh your
physiological expression is a complement
to your life experiences those people
that are happy are healthy as i said
when you're in the honeymoon you didn't
get sick in the honeymoon that's when
you're absolutely healthy but when you
got caught back up into real life that's
when illnesses start to occur so we
always look at oh i must be sick there
must be something wrong with my biology
when it turns out
it didn't begin with your biology only
about two percent of illness is actually
connected to genetics let's say
98 of illness is not just genetics it's
environment so when a person says i have
the breast cancer gene
and people think oh i'm going to get
breast cancer and i said well wait wait
50 of women that have the breast cancer
gene get cancer
what about the 50 that have the gene and
didn't get the cancer and we never study
that side we only study the side that
got the cancer and you find out well
what is it that the 50
do
that don't have the cancer yet have the
gene what's different the answer is
their lifestyle is different their
stresses their fears their concerns are
are not the same as the one that get the
illness the genes are like give you a
propensity to get a disease but that
propensity is based on how you perceive
life
and it's interesting uh studies show
that when children get adopted into a
cancer family the adopted child will get
the cancer with the same percentage of
probability as any of the natural
sibling and you say yeah but the the
child came from totally different
genetic stock and the point is yes it
wasn't the genes that promoted the
cancer it was the lifestyle that
promoted the cancer especially the
lifestyle of stress
and then i said well if stress is
causing lifestyle i can look around at
the world and i go my god no wonder
everybody's sick every day is filled
with more stress than the day before and
if you buy into the stress you take that
disharmonious vibration essentially
bring it in your life and you end up
with disharmony inside your body your
life is a reflection of what you see
rule number three get rid of the frail
image because we've been so programmed
to devalue ourselves and deep you know
disempower
ourselves that we look at ourselves as
victims and frail
uh biological entities you know ripe for
bacteria to eat us up and all these
other things it's like this is totally
untrue
so the issue is we have to start from
that belief and change these beliefs of
who we are we are profoundly powerful
people look you can walk across hot
coals you know
a woman can lift a car off of an infant
without thinking about it
down south the
baptist fundamentalists of the
pentecostal faith work themselves up in
a jesus state and drink strychnine in
toxic doses to demonstrate that god
protects them they're not harmed by the
strychnine i mean you can walk across
fire you can drink poison you can lift
thousands of pounds
where's the frail image come from and
that's a belief
but the problem is if you believe you
are frail if you believe you are
susceptible if you believe you have a
terminal illness
they manifest because that's called the
nocebo effect rule number four change
your thoughts
they did a recent study
where they looked at some genes
controlling inflammation
and then they had they read the genes of
these people
and then the people went to eight hours
of meditation
and at the end of eight hours the
genetic activity was completely changed
in other words you can change the genes
in just eight hours of a meditation and
that means how powerful your thought is
in controlling your biology
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five take control of
your consciousness i don't want to say
don't go to the doctor so i'll go back
just 20 years ago the last time i went
to a doctor okay i went to a doctor
because i had pneumonia and i said to
myself well yeah i can see why at that
moment in my life there was so much
stress going on in my life that i could
see i was i had opened my system up to
that but then i also realized okay well
i can you know handle this with my
consciousness but then i realized the
bacteria were doubling and they're
growing faster than i can handle my
consciousness so i said okay now is the
time for some penicillin but the concept
of it was i don't rely on the penicillin
and and all i had to say was look i get
back on my feet and i go
it was my responsibility
and if i don't get into that same
stressful situation again
then i won't have to go through this
again and it's been 20 years so it's
intelligent learning yes don't don't
discard
the element of medicine until your
consciousness gets high
and the fact is when people have lower
consciousness
because they're not strong enough in
their consciousness to really manifest
everything they want they really need to
take care of themselves more eat better
better nutrition do more exercises do
these things to add to your health but
the surprising thing is if you get more
and more and more conscious there's a
point where you get so conscious then
you become like the
the the person we refer to as jesus who
does all these miracles and well and
what did what what did jesus say about
the miracles he said
you could do these better than i can do
them but you don't believe and that is
the absolute truth because when you
fully have control of your consciousness
with that belief you do create the
miracles the miracles of spontaneous
remission for example a person
terminally ill who all of a sudden says
i'm not buying this i'm going to change
my vision of life and the moment they
change their perception
they have what's called a spontaneous
remission again that would be called a
miracle but what was it taking full
control of consciousness and manifesting
a life of being fully conscious and
present and seeing what brings harmony
into your life and avoiding or
eliminating as best you can any of the
disharmony that exists on the outside
because disharmony will make disharmony
inside rule number six create your
desires well i probably don't have to
tell you this if you've been watching tv
reading the newspaper going online or
even looking out your window the world
is in a state of upheaval crises are all
over the planet crises based on
economics politics religion race are
upsetting the nature of civilization as
we have known it well this is not an
accident actually this is right on time
on time yes we're facing an evolutionary
upheaval the significance is profound
science has recognized that human
behavior is precipitating the sixth mass
extinction of life on this planet five
times in the history of this planet life
was thriving in some event wiped out
from 70 to 95 percent of all life the
last time this happened 66 million years
ago a comet hit the planet upended the
ecosystem and the dinosaurs disappeared
forever
well guess what we are now in the sixth
mass extinction human behavior is
causing this the way out is to change
behavior but to understand that we need
to understand that you are not a victim
not a victim of your genes not a victim
of the world as quantum physics
emphasizes consciousness is creating our
life experiences when i show up on
september 27th in copenhagen on friday
night i'm going to provide a
presentation to inform you why this
upheaval is occurring the future of our
evolution and more importantly how
powerful you are in creating the
character of the life you want as
quantum physics the most valid science
on this planet acknowledges
consciousness is creating our life
experiences well my presentation will go
deep into the nature of consciousness
and how our mind controls our genes
controls the behavior that we have and
the life that we express and when you
understand that you've been programmed
and it's time for us to get out of this
program to recognize how truly powerful
you are
this is the opportunity to take charge
of your life and so what we need to
understand is this
a
you are not a victim of your heredity
because epigenetics the new science
reveals that you are controlling your
genetic and behavioral activity and more
so
we want to understand a very important
fact
there's more to us in this physical body
that there's a field of energy with our
identity which is also recognized as a
spirit and if you recognize how powerful
you really are and that you are more
than this physical body you will have
the opportunity to take charge of your
life and create the wishes and desires
and aspirations that you seek rule
number seven don't let your mind limit
you the belief that is taught is that
biology in the world we live in operates
according to newtonian principles
unfortunate part about that is quantum
mechanics 100 years ago said that's
obviously not true and physicists know
this is not true and yet medicine
doesn't buy into it because it still
focuses on the material reality and lets
go of the invisible shaping fields that
quantum physics emphasizes as primary
okay so we got we have to change that
belief system we have to get people to
recognize that the field and the
thoughts and all these other things are
as important as anything else in shaping
the matter we live in
uh number two uh the belief which i you
know i blew away years ago but it's
still being taught in school is the
concept that genes control life
this is totally false genes control
nothing
control is an action
a gene is a blueprint it's a physically
literally a string with blueprint data
on it
why is that relevant well it's
interesting go to an architect's office
and the architect's working on a
blueprint and then lean over the
architect's shoulder and say is that
blueprint on or off
and he looks at you
the blueprint's not on or off it's a
blueprint yeah but we talk about genes
being on and off like genes are turning
on and genes are turning off and the
question is but genes are blueprints
they can't turn on and off there is no
on and off it's just the blueprint it's
a pattern
what we have failed to focus on because
we gave genes a character of
self-actualization that my genes decided
to do something it's like okay now we're
a victim of the genes but it turns out
biologists know that this is not true
biologists know that genes are not
turned on and off genes are red or not
red like blueprints
then all of a sudden it says well it's
not the blueprint that's important if
the blueprints were self-actualizing an
architect could go by a building site
drop the blueprints off come back two
weeks later and the building will be
there that's what we think about
animals and plants uh the genes are
blueprints and their control all this is
like no
the blueprints are important i'm not
saying they're not you got the bad
blueprints you got some problems going
on here but the issue is it's not the
presence or absence of a blueprint it's
whether the blueprint is being read and
then you say well then who reads the
blueprint the answer is a contractor
and who's the contractor
the mind is the contractor the mind
reads genes the mind can change the
genes read out here here's something so
blow away that most people can't in
their conventional world make sense of
it because it's like it goes like this
the mind through what is called
epigenetic mechanisms
can
start with a single gene blueprint
and create over 30 000 different
versions of products from the same
blueprint 30 000 different products from
the same blueprint all of a sudden you
realize my god
you can infinitely vary the expression
of the gene and the answer is yes and
why has this become relevant to all of
us and the answer is because many of us
think genes control our lives and yet we
don't realize that we modify the readout
of the genes so we could be totally
healthy and our mind can cause cancer
our mind can cause any disease diabetes
anything like that
and and what's interesting is the flip
side
is some people come here with actually
defective genes
and guess what with their mind
they can rewrite those genes and make
them normal so the genes are not the
limiting factor it's the mind rule
number eight don't try to change someone
the simple truth is sad vijay said
you cannot change anyone but yourself
and if you try
and you start to realize you put all
that effort in to help somebody and it
doesn't come back
they're not affected by it you're the
one that's affected by it
if you know this the best thing to do is
recognize you can be a model
of what you want
but you can't really make anybody else
unless they want it
they will not change
so
helping somebody
only works if they ask for the help
if they don't ask for that help
that you're using up your energy and
it's not coming back
and i
really feel that's the most important
thing because how frustrated we feel
when we know that somebody could do
better or be healthier
and and you could help them and they're
not listening
it's not in their program at that time
when their program is ready to change
they will come to you
and ask for the help instead of us going
to them
it will save your energy save your life
and your joy and you could use it to a
much better effect by creating an area
an aura an energy around yourself that
others want that
and then you will become the teacher
and that's what it's all about rule
number nine redefine happiness you talk
about again in in your first book about
how
cells automatically move away from
toxicity
and towards nutrition yes and it seems
that
as human beings that's something that
we're trying to do but we get it wrong a
lot of the time we're trying to move
away from unhappiness or what we think
makes us happy and towards what we think
makes us happy but we get it muddled up
don't we well yeah but you see the key
word you said is what we think makes us
happy so i mean i was caught in that in
the old days too before i became aware i
thought at one point wow
i'm gonna buy that little you know that
car but bought a car that looked like a
ferrari called the pantera back in the
70s and i thought okay i'm gonna be
happy i i got this great car so i got
the car and about like three days later
it's like now i got this car i'm not any
happier and a matter of fact i got now
three speeding tickets because every day
i took the car out uh of course i
couldn't go 30 miles an hour with it so
uh
every day it was like the car became a
burden to me and it was all of a sudden
said well you know that whole program
that that ferrari is going to make you
happy
that that was a missed program it wasn't
the car that makes you happy
and i started to find out it wasn't the
material things that make you happy what
makes you happy love makes you happy
good food will make you happy harmony in
your environment makes you happy these
things are the
harmony environment where's the price
tag on that one you know
basically having a relationship with
somebody that supports you and fulfills
you where's the price tag
we always bought the oh money gives you
happiness so we have
all those billions of people out there
every day running in the streets how
much money can i make because if i get
enough money i'm going to be happy and
then you find out even people the most
money are not happy and it was
programming was wrong
if we were programmed to seek out
companionship and community and love
that's where you make us happy and rule
number 10 the last home before some very
special bonus clips is locate the
problems on a beautiful spring day bill
is celebrating his 16th birthday and his
father handsome the keys to the car and
says bill
this is your first solo trip please be
careful and enjoy this experience
thanks mom thanks dad for letting me use
the car
he's very excited when he sees his
friends and waves hello to them being
the proud owner of a new driver's
license
hi miles hey i really like your new
electric train set
[Music]
hi gabe lily annabelle i want to come
and visit you tomorrow and jump on your
trampoline
oh this is so wonderful
and he drives down the street further
and all of a sudden something catches
bill's attention
oh the check engine light is flashing
it's red
i don't know what to do something might
be wrong but i told dad i'd take care of
his car and the engine lights flashing i
don't know not sure what it is bill
drives into the local gas station where
he sees the mechanic
there's a gas station i'm gonna go in
there
[Music]
wow i'm lucky i made it into the garage
before anything went wrong with the car
well bill what simply raised a problem
here well hi mr john i'm having a
problem with the service engine light
that's flashing i don't know what to do
about it
well they'll gotta be easy fix you go
wait in the waiting room and i'll come
and get you when the job is done thank
you mr john my dad will be real happy to
have the car fixed bill goes into the
shop and the mechanic gets behind the
wheel
well it's the red tech engine life for
sure
and he puts his hand up under the
dashboard and he pulls out the light
bulb from the surface engine light
warning lamp oh that got a good idea
[Music]
well that'll stop it from blinking for
sure
now the lamp isn't flashing anymore the
engine is running the car seems to be in
very good condition
wow the check engine light is off i'm so
happy mr john fixed this car because dad
would be very happy too
happy to be a service bill he feels very
happy and excited about this because now
he's going off to finish the wonderful
drive in the country that he started a
little while ago but
unbeknownst to bill
the problem has not been solved with the
issue in this car oh no
oh no no
i thought the car was fit i thought it
was [ __ ]
and the moral of the story is very
profound because it's a metaphor about
life
consider your body as a vehicle such as
a car
however instead of a dashboard with
lights on it we have emotions and
symptoms that express how our vehicle is
running so we should recognize this when
we have feelings in our body and when we
have symptoms
these are not negative experiences these
are very important information providing
awareness messages these are messages
that something is going on in our body
that we have to deal with
but by eliminating the symptom
we didn't eliminate the problem
we have a wonderful protection system
called the adrenal system and when we're
really stressed the adrenal hormones go
through our system shut down our immune
system shut down our growth and
maintenance of the body while we
allocate all the energy to run away well
this is not a problem if the fear is
something like a saber-tooth tiger that
shows up we can run away and escape and
then go back to growth again i'm not
saying in terms of fear to throw caution
to the wind yes there are legitimate
fears out there
but the extent of the fears that we've
been programmed with are so overblown at
this point that we are weakening
ourselves
and through the stress hormones that are
released in our body we are becoming
incapacitated so therefore it's not to
let go of fear fear is very important
it's required for our survival but to
recognize a cycle of 24 7 365 is
detrimental to our health and our
vitality now is a time for us to take
care of ourselves take care of our
community and take care of nature as
well and when we go inside we must
remember to reprogram our limiting fears
about the world and ourselves and
recognize how truly powerful we are but
to do that we must stop the stress
hormones from controlling our life it's
time for us to take our power back
and not live in fear because that is
what weakens us
and it is love
that empowers us money is the equivalent
of energy so you can buy energy with
your cash and the significance about
that is if you're frugal and take care
of your money and keep a balance then
you always have this energy in your bank
account energy in which you can live
however obviously if you waste this
energy then you actually interfere with
your own survival so you don't really
want to go out and just throw away your
money and so basically i really want to
show you that this is an important
insight into the nature of our own
health and our biology in the world we
create in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energy is in coins called atp
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to atp as
the coin of the realm the significance
of atp is this
is that atp molecules are like units of
gasoline like gallon of gas that are
used to fuel our biological processes so
to stay alive we have to have all this
atp so there's an atp account in your
body right now but the question is how
do you use this atp and now here's an
important fact that
25 of the total energy in your whole
body is used to operate your brain so
all of a sudden you start to recognize
that the brain uses energy at the rate
of muscles of a marathon runner so a
brain and muscle activity are pretty
much the same and so why is this
important because as you're using your
brain as you're using your thinking you
are actually using energy now why is
this relevant the answer is very simply
this because the way we've been using
our thoughts are not necessarily
productive a matter of fact sometimes
our investments of our thoughts are
actually counterproductive because our
thoughts create a reality that we then
have to overcome so basically it says
that we must start to become aware of
our thoughts and why is this important
because thoughts represent units of
energy every time you have a thought you
use energy
why this becomes relevant is if i give
you a checkbook for your bank account
you don't go down the street and just
write checks to people like oh hey
you're a nice looking guy here's 10
bucks for you and oh here little girl go
out and buy yourself a little car here's
a thousand dollars for you and you don't
give away your money why because giving
away your money is giving away your life
so basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand
now what i'm trying to tell you is this
you have an energy budget in your body
the energy is what keeps you alive when
you start using energy and writing
checks where you get no return from your
energy then it's exactly the same as
writing checks out of your bank
checkbook and giving away your cash so
why this becomes important is the
biology of belief
reveals how our thoughts create our
reality
and if you start investing in thoughts
that are counterproductive thoughts like
fear or what am i going to do and how am
i going to escape this problem or how is
this going to go wrong and all these
other kinds of thoughts that are
negative kinds of thoughts then realize
this
you are actually not just using your
energy for having these thoughts but
these thoughts are also what come into
your reality what you focus on with your
thoughts your brain will manifest as
reality in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans
said we have been led to believe that
the universe is a great machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe
is immaterial
it's mental and
spiritual live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about it why is that and
so important as uh assad vijay had just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right
i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world i was looking for
relationships i kept failing at them
okay i end up in the caribbean teaching
at a medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the caribbean and hang out i
have a villa on the beach and i got my
own place and
and i still wasn't able to find anybody
but i kept looking because i said i i
need a relationship i need a
relationship so
i meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know i've got a
future that's like she'd do what she
wants and i thought well if you're not
doing anything why don't you uh you want
to come and stay with me in my villa on
this beautiful island
she looked at me and she looked at me
and then she said
i can't be with you
and i sort of like stop for a moment and
she looked at me and she said you're too
needy
it hit me i said oh my god
what am i looking for a relationship why
because you're not happy so if you're
looking for a relationship because
you're not happy then you're depending
on that relationship to make you happy
so that's not a a nice relationship it's
co-dependency if i give you this place
to stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes
after she said that i i was stunned for
a moment i can't be with you you're too
needy she said and i was
and then all of a sudden i said thank
you thank you very much it was sort of a
slap in the face right blessing in
disguise right
it totally was it was like wake up and i
walked away from that and i looked at my
life i said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the caribbean you got a villa
you got money in your pocket because you
get paid and there's nothing to buy in
the caribbean anyways you got i said
you're healthy you got money you got a
great place to live you have a most
wonderful job i go you can't be happy
with that that's what i said to myself
i said how can i
you know i'm looking for this person to
make me happy i said oh no first i make
me happy yeah and then when i make me
happy
that changed and it did what happened is
i stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
i love where i live do you love to see
you oh i love the sea you like it oh i
love my job and all of a sudden i
started focusing on hey these are things
i love i guess what
i didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right a hundred percent because once
i didn't need them i wasn't like
where i was like i don't care it's
fascinating how it works then they
showed up they showed up because i did
not need that was the word because need
puts pressure on that other person that
they have to provide
and then they didn't have to provide it
was like hey let me hang out with you i
don't have to provide anything i could
just be me i go yeah you be you i'd be
me we have a great time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need
for a relationship
until i was happy with myself
and until that had once i was happy with
myself and i didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away i was cloning stem
cells back in 1967
40 years ago
and the significance was while i was
doing this research i was also teaching
medical students so i was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits behavior
your physical characteristics etc and
what my research revealed when i was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound i put one stem cell in a petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks i
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then i did the
experiment an experiment was to take
some cells out of the dish and put them
into a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it
so i take the cells out of my stem cell
dish put them in a separate dish with a
different environment and the cells form
muscle
but then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there i was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone i said
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so i started to
really say oh my goodness here i am
teaching genes control life
to the medical students and yet the
cells were revealing to me that hey they
all had the same genes but it was the
environment that i put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is if i took
my dish with plastic petri dish with
cells and it moved it from a healthy
environment to a less than healthy
environment the cells get sick and if i
were a doctor of cells i you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again science it says
there are two minds that are operating
at the same time one is called the
conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science has recognized 95 of the
day because we are thinking 95 of the
day our behavior is now controlled by
the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community
so what is the difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are
disempowering self-sabotaging
and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
how do you change the subconscious mind
say how did it learn in the first place
i say what was the first one i say theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than consciousness
you have to slow down the brain to a
much slower vibration then it goes into
the subconscious mind
that's why um hypnotherapists in the old
days they had a watch and they would
swing it back and forth so the watch
would swing and they would tell the
person
you're getting sleepy
you're getting tired and the reason they
say that is because that shuts down the
conscious vibration and the next
vibration is theta
which is hypnosis so to get you into
hypnosis first i have to get your
conscious brain to stop
and then
in hypnosis state theta the vibration
theta
then whatever is coming from the outside
is not going into my conscious mind
whatever i see on the outside is going
into my subconscious program
so if you want to change the
subconscious you have to talk to the
subconscious and go how you do that well
number one hypnosis
and i go oh what i need to see the
hypnotherapist i go no this is the cool
part
i say why i said we have different
vibrations the lowest vibration is dealt
as sleep the next higher vibration is
theta hypnosis imagination the next
higher vibration is alpha calm
consciousness and the next higher
vibration is called beta which is like
school room like what we're doing here
consciousness okay
i go so why is it wrong i say when
you're asleep you're at the lowest and
when you start to wake up you go up
first to theta uh and that's like in the
morning where you're half awake and half
of sleep and and then i say but then
when you're awake you're in alpha now
you're in consciousness and then when
you go to work you're in beta which is
like the working consciousness
but when you come home it reverses
so i come home from work i'm in beta but
i relax oh the consciousness vibration
slows down the alpha
and here's the fact the moment that the
vibrations get a little lower than alpha
consciousness is now shut off for the
night you're sleeping yeah but there's a
period of time after alpha shuts off
before it reaches delta the lowest one
there's a period of time of theta i go
why is it relevant i said you put
earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want
a self-help program of have make a
relationship be healthy do a job
whatever you get the program self-help
program i say you put it on on a cd
player let's say and you put the
earphones on and while you're still
awake just before you go to sleep you
can hear what's going on
but the moment you fall asleep
conscious minds shut off but guess what
data is on the work is getting done
right right you're getting a
self-hypnosis
with the earphones so whatever the you
didn't hear it you were sleeping
the subconscious mind was hearing it and
when you repeat that that's how you put
a new program in so that's number one
self-hypnosis i had tenure at the
university i walked out of the
university and said look i i
can't keep my integrity and at the same
time teach something i know was patently
wrong
so i walked out because i saw that
teaching the belief that genes control
life was very very incorrect when we
look at our lives and i tell you that 95
percent of your life is coming from the
subconscious program
this is not it's new on a scientific
awareness of how this mechanism works
but what's interesting is for 400 years
the knowledge that you could program
somebody and control their lives has
been available it was the jesuits who
400 years ago said
give me a child until it's seven
and i will show you the man
most people didn't understand what they
were saying and what it is is the first
seven years which we now know
biologically and scientifically is the
program period they knew that 400 years
ago and they said if i can get that
program in the first seven years that
program will determine the life of that
individual i'll show you the man because
they will represent the program
now the really important part is since
every one of us has been programmed
the the big issue is so what were those
programs because if i ask you so what
what program did you get when you were
one year old
i have no idea i wasn't really there
in fact you were actually being
programmed even before you were born the
last trimester of pregnancy
you were being programmed i go well this
is really a critical issue because the
first thing i'm telling you is your life
is 95
programmed
and most of that is is really
disempowering and of course the first
thing i would think is then
what are those programs so i could deal
with them so i want to make something
very easy for you so you don't have to
go and review your whole life and try to
figure out what the programs are save
you a lot of time
the fact is this you are playing the
program 95 percent of the day
meaning your life
is a printout of your program
so you don't have to go back in time to
review that would just actually irritate
the system more because every time you
review those things that unsettled you
when when you were younger it just
reinforces that same pain that you had
earlier so going back uh and finding out
who did what to who
is
more than just a waste of time it
actually will set you back
a matter of fact there's an
old
phrase that people have heard and it
says don't kill the messenger over the
message
what that means is this don't go back
and blame all the people that did this
and that and that and that
that's irrelevant
who they are is irrelevant what's
relevant is what program did you walk
away with not who did the event but what
you learned so now i said okay
i've been programmed and i have no idea
what the program and i said then look at
your life and here's the simple
resolution
everything in your life that you like
and it comes to you
is because you have a program to support
that that's wonderful that means that's
great it's going to come to you because
that program is bringing it to you but
in contrast this is the one that's
important
anything you work hard to accomplish
anything you struggle over to make it
happen
anything you put a lot of effort in i
want this i'm going to work like crazy
i'm going to get this
my first question is
why are you working so hard
and the answer is very simple
anything you're struggling to try to
accomplish whether it's health or love
relationships whatever it is
if you're struggling it represents a
simple fact
your subconscious programming doesn't
support that conclusion
so the fact is what are my programs
look at your struggle
and wherever you're struggling
the struggle is not because the universe
won't provide for you the struggle is an
internal job the struggle is you're
trying to overcome
previous programming
that prevents you to go to that
destination so the wonderful part about
this understanding is you don't have to
to review your life you can look right
now at this one moment just look in your
head and say what are the things that i
keep trying to get and they they seem to
be elusive i can't get them they're
always out of reach i say
their their universe is not holding back
it's your own invisible subconscious
behavior when you're putting in a wish
and a desire put it in as if you already
have it
i am healthy
uh i am a good relationship person uh
you know i have a great job that what's
that i say it's like i already have it
and yet most people don't have it so
they'll say i want a great job i want a
great relationship i want to be healthy
and i go make a recording of those words
we just said that i want to be healthy
today right now tuesday we're going to
make a recording i say now come back in
one year and let's push the button on
that recording and we come back a year
later and it says i want to be healthy i
go it's a whole year and you still want
to be healthy still don't have it right
you're going to say i am healthy
all you're emphasizing i have a desire
to be healthy i want to be healthy i
have a desire to be healthy i go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy say i am
healthy but then you look and say yeah
but in reality i'm sick
and i go no no
the function of the mind is to take the
program and turn it into reality so if i
am sick but i put a program in i am
healthy the mind looks you know like
well wait a second the program is i am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the mind
create health in the body it doesn't
change the program
it changes the body and so the idea is
this every time we put a program in it
has to be as if you already have it in
spite of the fact you could be dying of
cancer i go i am healthy
it sounds kind of weird and i go don't
worry about it just put it on i am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up i'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this
that whatever you're downloading you
have to say it as if you already have it
because if you put a future tense on it
i will i want i say
if you record that that means you will
always will you know want to have it you
know i will do this you won't get there
so i just wanted to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't yo ho ho and apollo from the dead
man's on the la la la la la la la la
wow
what a glorious day to be sailing on the
sea
i think i should be checking my bearings
at this point
uh-huh north by northwest that's that's
right
hank told me
take a left at the island then follow
north by northwest and until i go
towards the sunset
but
it should be here somewhere
long island should be
somewhere but
[Music]
it's not here
i think i better check my calculations
again
so i left fort moresby at 12
and going at eight knots by 12 35 we
should have been over here take the left
at the island and then we follow the
tangent of the cosine of 381 for eight
minutes to the right and then we should
be approaching toward
kong island
uh
uh oh
i'm lost at sea
what should i do now
i knew i should have trusted my feelings
when hank gave me directions it just
didn't even feel right and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings if i did i would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should i choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that
ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right
or the heart will give you a feeling of
bad vibes less energy
a feeling that maybe this isn't the
right answer
so the significance is really profound
because the heart just reads energy
and
higher energy is more life less energy
is less life so
in making a decision yes it's acceptable
to do the analysis but before you come
to that final decision
please
check in with your heart
feel the feelings if the feelings are
good that means go toward that direction
but if you feel questioned about it you
feel weaker about it doesn't just feel
right the heart is telling you right off
that that energy is not good for you and
you should use some other decision oh
wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better life
[Music]
uh oh
i guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
scotty how many times have i told you
not to leave me off at sea you know i
can't swim meet me at the bridge you
have some splaining to do the new
science that is just coming into the
forefront of our world today
is is something called epigenetic
control
what i was teaching was genetic control
control by genes the new science which
is now coming around is called
epigenetic control and what that means
in the you understand the prefix epi
means above so you say epidermis that
means the layer above the dermis skin
if i say epigenetic control literally it
says control above the genes and this is
the new science and why is it profound
because when you teach genetic control
you teach victimization you didn't pick
the genes as far as we know the genes
control your traits you can't change the
genes so
you become victimized by your heredity
and the new science epigenetic control
reveals how your response to the
environment
as you change your response to the
environment you change the fate of
yourselves just like in the petri dish
that makes you a master because you are
the one that has the opportunity to
change your perception and response so
therefore you're the one that controls
your genes i don't care how much
knowledge is in your head if that
knowledge doesn't go into your
subconscious your life will stay exactly
the same as it was you can be the
brightest smartest academic and i say
fine did it change your life and the
answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming
and when you do that
you are all powerful in the creation of
your own life and so just walking around
and being able to recite all these
wonderful sayings and things that you
hear from all the wonderful teachers
that we have and you say oh yes i
remember that that's a good quote that's
a nice quote oh that's a wonderful
saying it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying
and that was the total transformation of
a life that on an academic level was
successful on a personal level i don't
even want to talk about that uh but it
changed everything why
because instead of having to chase after
life
after this understanding
things came to me the light will bring
it to you
the only thing that's in your way of the
light is a block in your belief that
other people have put into your
programming
you take your knowledge that you have
make it your subconscious program and
you will manifest all of the wonderful
spiritual wisdom that you have heard
throughout your whole life is not words
now
it is life and behavior and that's our
destination everything you do in your
life you put out energy for therefore
start to review what you're doing in
your life because if you're putting your
energy into things you cannot change in
this world that is exactly the same as
writing a check and just throwing away
your money to the outside because you
get nothing back from it so think about
this very interesting reality that you
have this energy checkbook and every
time you use energy you have to say is
the use of this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where i'm going to use up all my energy
and will i have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that i'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear uh not
only are you just wasting your energy
but as in the biology belief
these negative thoughts these negative
stresses actually impair your immune
system and bring on disease itself the
thinking is not that much in our control
the brain is operating as i said 95 from
the subconscious
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the the first thing how does a
subconscious learn and that's a very
critical thing uh the conscious mind can
learn from reading a book so you the
subconscious mind can read a self-help
book and you go wow that sounds really
great and then you find you read the
book but your life is still the same and
this turns out why and the answer is
because the subconscious mind is more of
a habit mind things that you repeat over
and over again so the reality is if you
can stay conscious
be present
and when those negative thoughts come in
our head and psychologists tell us
seventy percent of the time the thoughts
that are going through our head are
negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work or this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no
change the belief right there just give
the more positive thing
as you repeat this more frequently and
you keep repeating it the subconscious
mind begins to learn so as a habit if
you stay conscious and you have to work
at it
and here's why people say how come only
five percent from conscious mind 95 from
subconscious because a conscious mind
can think into the future and think into
the past and solve problems then think
about it yourself most of the time
you're thinking about something well if
you're thinking you're using the
conscious mind well if you're using the
conscious mind for thinking then who's
running the show jesus told his
followers
all the miracles that i can do you can
do them but even better than i can and
you don't believe it and that was the
whole damn thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and i say well where's belief come from
mind i say you know what have you been
programmed you can't do and i said then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and i and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know you that what
you said was true
evenings just say i feel amazing i feel
amazing if you repeat that the mind will
will all of a sudden change how you feel
that's that's how it doesn't okay so i
say number one self-hypnosis number two
after age seven you still learn how to
do new things that become habits like
you didn't learn how to drive a car
until until later then seven but once
you know how to drive a car remember the
first day you got in it was like oh my
god looking out the windows checking the
mirror watching the gauges keeping your
feet on the pedals just correctly you
know looking paying all these attentions
like
and i say today you've been driving for
a while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am i going to do when i get to the
store
you're not even thinking about driving
why it's a habit okay i say well how'd
you get that habit because you're older
than seven how'd you get it i said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
i'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and i say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of subconscious
learns
repeating something over and over and
over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and i love it
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it like what the hell is that i
say you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and i say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say i am happy and
spite up the fact that what the hell is
going on you just say i am happy
i am happy
i am happy i go why what's going on i
say repetition
and there'll be a point where you'll
repeat it to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in i am happy i said then
what's the consequences of what's the
function of the mind take that program
and manifest it now that it's in there i
am happy i wake up one morning guess
what i don't have to say i'm happy it's
automatic i'm already happy all day long
why my program said that 95 is coming
from that habituation
you know repetition
of the exact thing you want not future
vision as if you have it now
we'll put it in a program so that's
first seven years hypnosis after seven
years uh repetition habituation is how
you change it
uh a sticky note people put that stuff
on a mirror or someplace and they go oh
yeah the little sticky note and i go
that is not repetition that's a
suggestion
a repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving the car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real
okay so the first two things are
uh hypnosis
second thing is repetition
and thirdly the most
you know
effective
uh is called energy psychology and i go
what's energy psychology
it's called super learning so what the
hell is super learning i go maybe you've
seen somebody read a book by picking up
a book and just moving their finger down
the page just like that just as fast as
that
and guess what
the subconscious mind the super computer
that it is has read every word just by
moving your finger down that has read
every word on that page and a person
using this super learning technique can
go into a bookstore open up a book in
five minutes later by thumbing through
each page turn the page turn the page
turn the page they can read a whole book
in five minutes that's super learning i
say if you can engage that function
you can also use super learning to
create
new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes
it's like
i go absolutely and it's so important
why because uh there's an old phrase
that's really critical it's called
necessity as the mother of invention
and i say what's happening we're facing
a mass extinction due to human behavior
that is compromising the web of life
humans are creating this through our
behavior our culture i say you want to
survive this epi this whole you know
extinction event
well then you have to create something
different
you have to change behavior i was a
scientist and as a scientist we don't
bring spirituality and mind into the
story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that
and my research uh on on stem cells uh
revealed that while i was teaching in
medical school that genes control life
my research revealed that it was the
environment in which the cells lived
that control the cells it was outside
information coming into the cells
and i remember how specifically in a
moment of time
that i was working on trying to
understand the mechanics from a
molecular point of view how does an
environmental signal control biology
and i was working not on the genes i was
working on the skin of the cell the
membrane
and it was
it was so profound i it's hard for me to
even describe it i'm working on the
understanding how does information from
the environment control biology and i
had
looked at the membrane for years and i
wrote a new definition of the mechanism
of the membrane
and i wrote this definition this is in
1985. it was about 2 a.m
and i wrote down the membrane
is a liquid
crystal
semiconductor with gates and channels
when i wrote that down there was a pause
and i said
i just i read something exactly like
that and right next to my first computer
macintosh was a book from a simple book
of understanding your microprocessor
and i opened it up and i said somewhere
and i open it right in the introduction
it said
a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with gates
and channels
and i thought oh what a coincidence
they have the same definition
and then in a couple of seconds i
started to say wait a minute
one for one the parts are exactly the
same i said oh oh my god
the membrane is a computer chip
and
on the surface of the cellar like keys
like on a typewriter
and and i started to realize oh my
goodness the environment
is typing
on the surface of the cell information
that went into the cell
and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
really exciting and i'm typing on my own
computer typing this information and
then i realized
i am outside of the computer
typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then i said
oh my god
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells
has a number of keys
that represent a pin number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same
keys on that each of us have a different
pin number to get into our own cells
it's our personal identity and these are
the keys and i realized oh my god
well we've been focusing on these what
are called receptors as the source of
identity i realized no
it's what's activating what's typing is
the identity and then it hit me and said
oh my god
my identity is not in the cell my
identity is a signal coming from the
environment typing in the keyboard and
then i said
oh
and the first thing that hit me was
i can't die
i'm not even in here
an instant the fear which all of us have
in our deepest bottom belief system is a
fear of our
mortality and when that moment of like i
can't die not as a devotional belief it
had nothing to do with that it was just
a mechanism i said oh my god i can't die
i'll tell you the same thing happened
with savages me tears started rolling
down my face
and this joy was an ache in my heart
that i've never experienced before i
spent 40 years in my head that's how i
became an academician and a research
scientist
and when this moment hit it was my heart
that blew open i refer to it as a heart
orgasm and
and that was the first time i
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence
and what happened was
i was overwhelmed
first with the fact that i was not
spiritual at 1 59 a.m
and at 2 a.m i was 100 spiritual you
have a very close friend you know your
friend's behavior and you happen to know
your friend's parent and at some point
you see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill
because bill's the first guy that says
how can you compare me to my dad and
everyone laughs because they're familiar
but i say no there's two very profound
points from that one story and profound
point number one
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad he got his programming from
his dad it's only bill who doesn't see
it yeah and profound point number two
we're all bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it we'll
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when i first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what i
learned but my subconscious programs are
still exactly the same so well i had
this wonderful knowledge my life still
wasn't anything i wanted to brag about
because it wasn't and
and as you know that old game well who
would you like to be and i could think
of anybody i'd rather be than me and yet
when i started to apply the new science
and rewrite the subconscious so it
supported me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
i put in the new programs all of a
sudden i started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life i was healthier i had been to a
doctor in 20 years i i don't need that i
don't take any of their drugs why
because
most of the illness is just from the
stress of not living in harmony and when
you learn to to get rid of the limiting
programs that we got as children and put
in programs that support you guess what
then all of a sudden the place turns
into heaven
and it's interesting people i tell
people you create your own life and then
they look around and go i don't want
responsibility for this but i say well
you didn't know you were creating with
these unconscious beliefs and and yet
then i tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels and love i said
go back to that time when you first fell
in love
let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah i was i was healthy
as anything i said you have energy oh i
had so much energy made love for days in
a row without even eating and i go yeah
and i go uh and how was life for you it
was so exciting i couldn't wait for the
next day so i said in this little period
that you you know that i refer to as a
honeymoon i say
wasn't life like heaven on earth and
they go well yeah and i go you know that
was not
an accident that was an actual creation
and you say but what was different that
made life uh
so heaven on earth during love and the
answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date i say
especially the women i said how long did
it take you get dressed and they say i
was 15 minutes and i was out of the
house and i say now tonight you're going
to go on a date with this person who has
just rocked your world and i said how
long does it take you to get dressed
it's like my god it may take an hour or
two and i say
yesterday 15 minutes today an hour or
two what's the difference yesterday i
got dressed by habit because i get
dressed every day but tonight i am
looking in the mirror meaning i am
self-conscious i am making sure that i
represent myself to be the fully the
best individual i can be and when both
parties are not relying on the habit and
both of them are saying i'm creating the
best i can be they're living in the
moment of the now they're being very
mindful they're being very present and
guess what
heaven on earth is created many people
may think well hold on a second so i can
take five minutes and i can totally
change my life and that's all i need and
i think
that's a really a wonderful possibility
but the probability is this are you
going to hit the right statement
that is the one that you need to change
your life okay uh let's say someone's
overweight
and they say in their mind i i am you
know a weight a number they like i am
125 pounds and you're not
uh and i say uh so i want to change my
weight and i put a program in i'm gonna
lose weight
and i go but well wait
that extra poundage uh that might be due
to protection like what do you mean
if i as an as a young person was abused
then the consciousness is if i'm a heavy
person they won't bother me anymore
and so the weight isn't due to just
eating food the weight
moved to
i'm safer
being heavy than i am i say well if you
want to change your weight you can talk
about the weight all you want but until
you adjust the problem from the the fear
of you know that i'm going to be abused
that's where the problem came from it
didn't come from eating food over here
so i said yeah well you can change
beliefs uh sometimes i like to give a
visual a matter of fact i visualize a
big spider web which has like circles
and then lines coming out you know like
a web okay
and so there are links as you go around
there's also anchors where the web is
anchored at a couple of places and i go
each belief is like a link
in that spider web and you can do one
link and another link and another link
really changes fire web
but if you do a belief that is an anchor
and you change the anchor belief and
that anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's possible
right the point is this
sometimes a police statement knocks out
a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support in our mind we
start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough i'm
not safe i'm not secure and i say oh
these thoughts i was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and i go yes
this is really true
i said well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head
that if i have a thought it's just for
me not for anybody else it's inside and
it's working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
magneto encephalograph i say what's
unique about that i say read your brain
i say yeah but so does eeg i say yeah
but eeg you put the wires on the head
and you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what i'm reading and i
said what's different about meg
the probe is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i said well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
i'll give you this most wonderful quote
i use it the other day in a lecture from
albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite the definition the field is
the invisible energy right now you're in
a field there's cell phone broadcast
television television radio broadcast
all kinds of information coming across
but guess what each one of you is a
broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives
and if enough of us collectively have an
energy that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively
creating reality with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end we all have approximately 50
trillion cells in our body and these
cells are all self-sufficient they have
their own memory they have their own
immune system and in fact you're also
going to say that for 2.75 billion years
there was only one celled organisms
alive on the planet yeah and and the
nature is
as the single cell evolved to be the
most intelligent and could be it ran
into a physical limitation because
intelligence is physically tied up with
the membrane or skin of the cell you can
only have so much membrane
so evolution apparently stopped it was
like two and a half billion years just a
single cell organism then it said well
how can you have more evolution the
answer is cells decided to come together
in community because when cells come
into community they share awareness so
there's more awareness with ten cells
and there is with one cell and there's
more awareness with a million or a
billion or a trillion so when you look
at a human being while we see ourselves
as single entities the truth is we are
made out of 50 trillion amoeba like
cells and so our body is this giant
community
and what makes it very exciting as you
mentioned is well in my own work with
cloning cells i can take a cell out of
your body and it can live outside of you
why it has its own intelligence it has
essentially every function in your body
is present in a cell so my
seven-year-old vision manifests to be
true when i got older to realize cells
are miniature people and then you say
well what about happens in the human
body and i go this is where the issue
comes in is because you have 50 trillion
cells living in community but your mind
is the government
when a government works in harmony with
the people
then the people thrive and the community
is is in good health and grows but when
a government is not really supportive or
not working in in harmony with a
community then the government could
cause the
the nature of that community to fall
apart and even lead to to to the end of
the community well that's what we're
finding out our mind is the government
and when we entertain harmony and and
the right living and balanced with
nature and with each other then we
provide our 50 trillion cells with very
life-supporting information and
chemistry so harmony means
giving the body
good food yes not being stressed out
absolutely living in a in a happy
environment yes
basically it says uh it's as i said when
i had my petri dish of cells if i put it
from a healthy environment to a bad
environment the cells got sick but you
didn't have to give them drugs uh but
all you did is take the the dish from
the bad environment and put it in a good
environment and the joke which i like to
tell people is
well this happens in a plastic petri
dish but guess what
we are skin covered petri dishes
underneath our skin
is 50 trillion cells living in a dish
and the culture medium is the blood and
so when i change the culture medium to
plastic dish i change the fate of the
cells and i say well then what controls
the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is
my thoughts influence my brain and the
brain releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when i'm in stress or i'm
afraid of the world i release different
chemistry into the blood than if i open
up my eyes and i find myself in love i
release completely different chemistry
and it's like well all i have to ask an
individual is how do you feel when
you're in total love or how do you feel
when you're in fear and the answer is
well i feel totally different i guess
what
all the cells
are bathed in that chemistry and so the
the feeling of love produces totally
different chemistry in the blood
chemistry that supports growth and
healing of the body and supports the
immune system and in contrast
when we perceive reasons to be afraid
and we release stress hormones into our
body
we actually shut off the growth
mechanisms and the immune system to
serve to save the energy why because if
you believe you're going to have to run
from that lion
you want all the energy available to run
from a line so when a person is in
stress
they allocate their energy reserves for
fight or flight
but take it at the expense of the health
of the system the immune part of the
system and so the more stress you're
under the more bad chemistry in a sense
of not supporting you you that you
experience uh and and it's a very
important point
in our evolution stress or fear was not
the main stay of life the mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment
every now and then a saber-toothed tiger
would come okay now it's time to be
stressed out now it's time to run but
the point is once you escape from the
saber-tooth tiger in the old days then
it's like oh back to health and harmony
and i say what about today's world
today's world is 24 7 run from the tiger
and this is not biologically sustainable
because
the chemistry of protection
contrasts with the chemistry of growth
maybe we should start focusing on what
we want and not focusing on on what
we're afraid of and that's where the
bigger problem comes from at this moment
and recognizing this has been brought up
before we're birthing a new civilization
and recognize this
birth is always
associated with some pain a little blood
uh as the process unfolds
and so when we look at the world and we
say it's struggling right now i say yeah
this is a birthing pain that we're
experiencing
and you have a choice you could focus on
the pain
or you could focus on the baby
that's coming here
and think about it know how much of a
woman is screaming the moment before the
baby comes out
uh the moment the baby's out
there's no more pain anymore it's gone
because the love has covered everything
be you know and this is what we're at
now this is where we are
we are creating something new let's not
focus on on the pain part
because it's the birth that is the most
amazing experiencing
experience that is coming to this planet
right now
all of us are uh on the threshold of
seeing a new civilization this is an
amazing time
in human civilization we're here to
observe
an evolutionary event unfolding
immediately in front of your eyes but
we're more than observers we're
participants
and that's what this whole uplift
program is all about
each one of us
is contributing a vibration a
consciousness a thought
and building something so beautiful
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there